welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel's agents of shield
after years of unclear canonical
connection to the mcu
just concluded its series with some of
the biggest smoking gun answers
that set the stage for marvel's upcoming
storylines spoiler warning though before
i continue because i am going to talk
about the final episode and season of
agents of shield which you should
definitely watch but here i'm going to
explain the four
huge implications this series finale has
on the
mcu going forward because i am a marvel
news pirate
and i plunder me scoops for me theories
from anywhere someone says the word
quantum
okay if you do watch agents of shield
i'm gonna skip over a ton of plot points
for this final season because again
here we're just talking about this
show's final flips to the mcu prime not
the great
meaty complex storytelling of agents of
shield's own internal universe
you want to know what happened watch the
show or get someone else to recap it for
you from the beginning marvel fans were
left a little uncertain
how much agents of shield connects to
the mcu films its central premise was
what if agent coulson survived his
apparent death in the avengers
early seasons followed the mcu film
timeline
the aftermath of the battle new york
events from thor of the dark world
hydra's takeover of shield during
captain america the winter soldier but
the key word there was
followed agents of shield would
reference the films but the films
never referenced agents of shield and
when avengers age of ultron came out in
2015 it was confirmed
agents of shield was in kind of a
separate universe and that the avengers
did not know
coulson was still alive now years later
avengers endgame did cast
james darcy as edwin jarvis in 1970 the
same actor who played jarvis on agent
carter
a series that was more closely aligned
to the universe of agents of shield but
casting the same actor is small potatoes
compared to the endless
mist opportunities by kevin feige and
his film directors
to at least acknowledge the existence of
coulson and his team
coulson didn't even get an invite to
tony stark's funeral but as
is my policy for weddings just because
you ain't invited doesn't mean you can't
still sneak in behind a portly out of
town relative and hit up the open bar
and agents of shield just crashed
feige's party
so by the agents of shield season 4
finale the show had mostly given up on
tie-ins to the prime mcu
earth nine nine nine nine nine because
feigie was keeping the show's writers in
the dark about what was gonna happen
infinity war and end game so
after like a vague mention of thanos is
coming
the series launched itself on its own
distant future timeline
and then jumping ahead to the final
season seven did a lot of cool things
with time travel in a timeline meddled
in a way that both cohered to
and distilled the time travel
explanation in
endgame see they called it the time
stream because when you're going back in
time and you change things throw in one
stick in the river doesn't ripple affect
it too much but
too many sticks and you got yourself a
dam that diverts the river
on a new path an end game they kind of
said how only infinity stone removal
branched the timeline
we think but here in agents of shield
too many of those changes
can change the timeline and then at the
end of the season
the character fitz returns from a
freaking quantum tunnel
he was in the quantum realm the whole
time midland with past events an attempt
to restore
all these characters in their origin
timeline before everything got messed up
look you went back in time and then you
branched off
but we can travel through something
called the quantum realm
so we we we can go in between timelines
god bless you fitz using the universal
time
travel sign language too bad smart
hulk's arms are too thick to fit in
frame
this is our first huge implication for
the mcu going forward
fitz establishes that the quantum realm
allows for what i have called horizontal
navigation
across alternate timelines this was the
missing piece
for how old cap was able to return to
the prime mcu timeline in end game
after living out his alternate branch
history with peggy carter
in that branch history cap would have
had to use some advanced tech beyond
tony stark's quantum navigation
to allow further time travel not just
down the hole of one's own timeline
but rounding the corner to the original
unchanged timeline that you came from
that is what fitz did fitz gave old cap
a logical framework for existing he
filled
eminem's holes along with the quantum
realm and timelines the other way the
mcu is expanding outwards is
to the cosmos to the stars the
transition of shield
into sword the final minutes of the
episode show daisy sousa and cora
on the zephyr 3 headed towards some
construction in space
nick fury showed up on a space station
in the far from home post credit scene
and
one division set photos show the sword
logo
sword standing for sentient world
observation and response department
it is believed that an agent of sword
series is in the works for disney plus
under the supervision of kevin feige you
know what that means lots of two-way
tie-ins with the mcu prime now it's not
clear if daisy and the rest would be the
stars of this agents of sword series
hopefully they play some role in it i'm
guessing marvel's bigger priority is
going to be introducing new faces
you know instead of making new viewers
feel that they have to go back and watch
seven
seasons of a show that the studio has
been pretending doesn't exist just might
think
but before we continue thank you to bang
energy for sponsoring this video
every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and it has
zero calories kid it tastes great
there's over 20 different flavors to
choose from this one
is sour heads which i gotta say isn't
too sour it's more like the nice sweet
aftertaste of like a sour candy we get
like the essence of sour
but not offensive and you're so
unoffended you wake up and you charge
through the rest of the day like you're
punching through metropolis skyscrapers
check out bang on instagram you can get
25 off with your order at bang
energy.com when you use the code
newrockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea and keto
coffee flavors you can also get clothing
fitness supplements all kinds of stuff
to be your best bang self thanks again
to bang energy for sponsoring this video
get 25
off at bang energy.com using the code
newrockstars25
okay another key implication from the
agents of shield finale comes in what
they didn't include in season seven
modok the crew revealed that they
planned to feature marvel villain modoc
on the series but that the higher ups at
marvel studios told them
no that they had other plans for the
character in development for a live
action even aside from the patent oswald
voiced animated series and development
for hulu not too long ago i explained
how modok
could be the mysterious benefactor
behind sunny birch from ant-man and the
wasp and
could be a villain in ant-man 3 a
reincarnated form of the disembodied
arnim zola
check out that video so that brings us
to our final big takeaway what is
what is not mcu canon going forward see
the final timeline that the agents of
shield return to
set one year after the events there's a
few details that don't add up
mack is now the nick fury replacement
director of shield he's on a helicarrier
and in the final shot of the series
behind coulson in the background the
biggest detail that changes
everything the triskelion shield
headquarters is still
standing why is this important well the
triskelion was destroyed in 2014
in the events of captain america the
winter soldier and as late as spider-man
homecoming set in 2016
it was still being cleaned up that must
mean that agents of shield
ends in a timeline in which the
triskelion was not destroyed
and most likely a timeline in which
thanos snap never happened
now it could be back in that 2014
alternate timeline that younger thanos
left an end game to come to the future
to fight them all either way this is not
present day
mcu-199999 and don't tell me shield just
like rebuilt the triskelion to look
exactly as it did before 10 years later
after the blip in 2024 like in the real
world they then
rebuild the twin towers exactly the same
that's not how humanity moves on from
disaster folks no
this triskelion was a deliberate clue
establishing this as an
alternate timeline and they did this to
suggest that the timeline designation
doesn't matter all of it can be canon
that's the way endgame left the marvel
cinematic multiverse whether it's agents
of shield
the netflix marvel series even the
deadpool and x-men films from a
different studio
they can all just be what-if histories
within the mcu multiverse
all of them canon and worth watching and
now accessible through magical quantum
bridges
that is if feige wants to do that sadly
if marvel tv wasn't under ike perlmutter
but
under feige's control seven years ago or
if agents of shield just started with
agent coulson as an oblivious life model
decoy from the beginning
we wouldn't have had this problem either
way agency will just crash the wedding
and the ball's in feige's court
on whether or not he's going to let them
stay and sing a little bit louder now
with aunt march
hopefully we'll learn soon with the
multiverse the quantum realm and agents
of sword will look like in the mcu when
we get news about things like wanavision
and the other marvel disney plus series
but for more marvel updates and
discussion join us on our discord server
by becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars follow me on
instagram
eaboss follow me rockstars and subscribe
for breakdowns of everything you love
thanks for watching and now sing with me
mcu crashers hey
hey oh i uh stand out like a sore thumb
okay i'm going i'm going i'm gone
[Music]
you